- [Instructor] In this off-white color,
I have a handful of statements
that you might hear folks say especially
in the United States,
and what we're going to think
about is are these statements
that you would typically
hear from a liberal?
And I'm gonna make a little key here,
so I'm gonna use a light blue for liberal.
Conservative, I'll use this salmon color
for conservative, or a libertarian?
So I'll do this white
color for libertarian.
Libertarian.
And I've pre-grouped these
statements into categories.
They could be views on social
issues or economic issues
and within each of those dimensions,
they could be views that
might want more social
or economic control or ones
that want less social or economic control,
and this isn't a perfect full sampling of
all of the major issues
that folks will talk about
and some of these things
kind of border on social
and economic, or some of them
could be viewed as more
control depending on
how you view it or less control,
but this is a first take on things.
So let's just go from the
top left to the bottom right,
and I encourage you to
keep pausing this video
and coming to your own conclusion.
So this first statement,
affirmative action is a good thing.
Would you expect that to come
from someone with a liberal,
conservative, or libertarian ideology?
Well, this would typically come
from someone with a liberal ideology.
Much of the ideas and policies
that liberals would favor
might be around curing
social injustice, so they might say,
hey, we don't have the proper
diversity in certain walks
of life right now, we don't
have a level playing field,
so we need to make sure
that people are properly represented,
and so that would be something
that you would hear from liberals,
and it would be something
that in general involves more control.
A libertarian or a conservative would say,
hey, we shouldn't try to
do social engineering here,
we should maybe make sure
people have equal opportunities,
but that doesn't mean
that you have to have equal
representation and outcome.
This next statement, marriage should be
between a man and woman.
Pause this video.
Who is likely to say that?
Well, that would typically come
from someone with a conservative ideology.
This would be around a theme that
many folks with conservative
ideologies would point
to values that are worth
preserving in a society,
that should not change,
and so that would
typically come from them,
while a liberal or libertarian
is more likely to say,
hey, what goes on between two people,
well, that's their decision
and really the government should
have no say on what they do.
We need tougher penalties
and policing to deal with crime.
Well, once again, that would
be something that you would
likely hear from someone
with a conservative ideology.
A liberal or libertarian
would be on the opposite side.
They would say, hey, I'm
afraid of too strict penalties,
too strict policing, I'm afraid
that the government is putting
too many people in jail.
So now let's go to fewer social controls.
So marijuana should be legalized.
Pause this video.
Who is more likely to say that?
Well, many liberals would
be likely to say that,
and also libertarians.
They would say, hey, once again,
what someone does within
their own privacy,
why should the government have a say,
while many conservatives,
and this goes back to values
and kind of social fiber, might say,
well no, some of these drugs,
they break down people's value system.
Maybe they lead to crime and
so a conservative would be more
likely to be against legalizing
something like marijuana.
The next statement.
Laws restricting gun
rights are unconstitutional
and won't have the intended impact.
Pause this video.
Who would say that?
Well, you would often hear a statement
like this from someone with
a conservative ideology,
but also from someone with
a libertarian ideology,
so libertarian ideology would
also say something like that,
and they would both cite
that people have a right
to protect themselves,
they might cite, hey, people have a right
to use guns for things like hunting,
and especially libertarians
might make the argument
that people need to be armed in order
to protect themselves from
an overly strong government,
from an overly strong police state.
So the next statement.
Same-sex couples should
have full marriage rights.
Who's most likely to say that?
Well, this is kind of
the opposite statement
of this one we saw up here,
and for the reasons we mentioned,
this is more likely to come
from someone with a liberal
ideology or a libertarian,
libertarian ideology.
And for them, it would be about
personal liberty and equal rights.
And so you might already see some trends
that the conservative
and liberals are kind
of mixed on the social when
it comes to more control
or less control, and don't read
too much into how many there are of these.
This is just, you could view
as a random sampling of some issues.
If I sampled more, you might
have more liberal boxes up here
or more conservative boxes down here,
but it seems like a mix.
But one clear thing that comes out
is that libertarians
on the social dimension
are for less control.
But what about the economic dimension?
So this first statement,
everyone has a right
to quality healthcare.
Who's more likely to say that?
Well, that would be a liberal.
Liberals, once again, they
think a lot about injustice
and inequality and they
want the government
to be proactive about it.
And so they would say,
hey, the government should
somehow supply universal
healthcare to folks.
Conservatives or libertarians,
not that they don't care
about injustice or inequality,
but they would argue that, hey,
when the government kind
of intervenes in things,
they don't, they have all sorts
of unintended consequences
and oftentimes do more harm than good.
The next statement.
Rent control is a good thing.
Well, once again, this is
likely to come from a liberal,
probably motivated from the idea
that if rents or living
costs are getting too high,
that this is a way to avoid
people being displaced
or being priced out of their neighborhood.
Now, conservatives and
libertarians would argue
that rent control distorts the market,
it actually makes the properties
that aren't on rent
control overly expensive,
and so it's probably
doing more harm than good.
The next statement.
Social safety nets are crucial.
Once again, this is likely
to come from someone
with a liberal ideology.
They believe that someone,
that the government has
a role in making sure
that everyone has a
basic standard of living,
so programs like food stamps or welfare.
Every worker has the
right to a living wage.
And living wage is sometimes,
you'll hear this in the context
of minimum-wage discussions.
Who would say that?
Well, once again, you're
likely to hear this from
someone with a liberal ideology.
They believe that higher
minimum wages are a good thing,
while conservatives or
libertarians would argue that,
no, that distorts the market
and actually you might
increase unemployment
and you might hurt the very people
that you're trying to help with some
of these efforts around minimum ages.
And what about here when we go
to less control on the economy?
Government intervention
in the free market will slow
the economy, hurting everyone.
Well, as you could imagine,
this is kind of the opposite
statement as these here,
because these once at the top
are all the government intervening
in a free economy in some way,
and so this statement is more
likely to come from a conservative,
some of the conservative
ideology or a libertarian.
And so when you look in
the economic dimension,
the distinction between
conservative and liberal,
at least when it comes to more control
and less control, become more clear.
On economics, liberals
tend to favor more control,
more government intervention with a focus
of trying to address social
or economic inequality or
environmental concerns,
while conservatives and
libertarians will often say,
well, that's gonna do more harm than good,
the government does have some functions
but it should really
be as small as possible
and free markets are what's,
in the end of the day, going
to make people better off.
So I will leave you there,
this is a very simple model,
but it helps us start to
think about these issues,
and so when you think about issues
and you read about it in the newspaper,
try to think about it in
this type of a framework.